west babylon new york a close-knit
suburban community located on long
island an hour away from manhattan best
friends colleen and naomi started as
waitresses at a small quaint restaurant
called classic american
then in the year 2000 they seized an
opportunity and bought the business from
their boss what do you think we're ready
to open in a couple of minutes classic
american was like my home i grew up here
i figured i knew everything there was to
know about the restaurant why not
everything's good okay oh thank you
we knew the business we knew the
customers and it was good this would be
the beginning of something great soon
after buying the restaurant colleen made
her son kevin the head chef
and her boyfriend dom the unofficial
manager give me uh two bags of raw
shrimp thanks i started hooking up with
colleen and then she said well i could
use you at the restaurant
so she's using
me i enjoy my job at college of america
because it's like a big family here big
hugs kev whoa it was good in the
beginning the first couple years place
was packed you didn't have to worry or
wonder if you were gonna be busy
now
you'll get maybe six or eight tables
it's scary
you have to ask yourself what did i do
wrong
so tonight's out every night soxia
we've run out of things on the menu all
the time we don't have clam ships
tonight
hey dom why do we run out of everything
how to wind up we haven't been busy
dom's job here at the restaurant is just
to order the food which is never done
it's always kind of a problem tom i need
some of that chicken i hear you panther
don't have to tell me eight times
any cucumbers on the line yeah no
yes yes no which one is it
hello
nobody leads this restaurant you got a
bunch of followers and no leaders the
problem with colleen and naomi is
they're too easygoing it's more of a
friendly relationship with the workers
rather than business
it's ridiculous do you want to go out
there no i don't know you know the
waitresses they're texting in between
working somebody's got to put these kids
in order
how many tables were there
not that many
nobody's making money we're not
successful and you're wondering how
you're going to keep doors open
home sweet home i was forced to move
back home i love my parents because i
couldn't afford
i cry on the way to work on the way home
from work
i cry about what we've become here and
what are we going to do
it gets to a point where you just dread
being here it kills me it really kills
me
i can't afford to close we need someone
to show us the way
[Music]
hey how are you dominic i'm the manager
how you doing very well thank you come
on in have a seat my goodness is this it
the dining room is so small this is it
not much to manage today
yeah is it normally this queen oh it's
saturday's yeah damn damn damn now you
look like you've been in this business
for 30 years i haven't really six years
what were you doing before that laying
brick
[Music]
it's you and who colleen and naomi okay
own the place i'm okay
i'm actually going out with colleen
you're going out with colleen yeah i've
seen go out with one of the owners yeah
ex-customer yeah right
can i meet the two owners dying to meet
them okay yeah bring them out please
you know this is colleen and naomi's
last resort if ramsay can't get this
place on the map we might just lock the
doors chef gordon ramsay colleen naomi
nice to meet you colleen nice to see you
naomi nice to meet danny help me um get
up to speed uh with classic american how
did you get to own it first off we
worked for the previous owner you were
working as a chef before no actually i
was a waitress waitress wow and what
were you doing i was a waitress
incredible and you bought it from the
owner yes how much uh 240 000
really yeah quarter million
for this
just the business not the property
how much is that that was 440.
wow so we're in for 700 grand so far
um how long have you owned the
restaurant for 10 years
straight up what do you think's the
worst thing is wrong with russia
problem number one would be what would
you say
i don't think it's just one thing i
think it's a lot of things give me one
[Music]
are you always know me this quiet no i'm
not chef ramsey makes me nervous because
i'm out of answers maybe my eyes are
closed you know maybe the head's so
stuffed that it's just not saying what
it needs to say
okay well listen um i'm gonna have a
good look at the menu taste the food and
uh catch up later
okay
enter a stranger's leave as friends
enter as a stranger
start dating the owner
[Music]
oh how are you today how are you hi i'm
ashley ashley i'll be your survivor okay
great i am freaking out having jeff
ramsey calm is very nerve-wracking i can
throw up right now
so how long have you been here uh ten
years ten years my god everyone's been
here for a substantial length of time
why have you been so loyal
it's like a little family great
wow huge menu about 100 options there
yes well help me out um you could do
fried calamari it's very good is it
mm-hmm it's one of my favorites let's go
for the fried calamari overseas salad
okay and then i'd be stupid not to have
the bomb the bomb burger the bomb burger
does it look like that uh yeah
do you know what i'm a big lover of mac
and cheese do you have any mac and
cheese yes yeah lovely that'll be all
brilliant you got it thank you
thank you order when i throw in the
macaroni and cheese
one fifth day
water up ash
that's my mac and cheese thank you that
was very fast for mac and cheese my god
[Music]
probably pre-made
yeah it's a mattel of goo that's gross
that doesn't even taste like it's been
cooked here yeah we don't make the mac
and cheese right no it tastes like is
that a big hit no it's where the kids
eat it
uh yeah that's dreadful poor kids damn
you think a menu with classic american
you'd at least make your mac and cheese
right yeah it's not good like
really sorry i don't really know what to
say because i'm not the one making the
food i'm just serving it what'd he say
he said it was gross
i just hope he doesn't run to the
bathroom
oh fry calamari overseas yourself
let's uh let's taste
not good
is really soft and sort of chewy
oh
uh i don't think i really should be
touching food yeah don't worry it won't
bite
yeah
is this fresh well it's frozen because
it tastes frozen yeah it is frozen
dreadful
anyway definitely not for me um i'll
finish thank you okay you're welcome
how are you making out ass they said
they were gross they're soft and chewy
what's soft and chewy
it's not crispy
it wasn't a great feeling when sending
back all the food you know uh it's what
we do every day we think we do a pretty
good job who wants the bomb next
everyone loves the bomb
that's one of our house specialties but
he's definitely going to enjoy that one
the bomb burger
wow
nice toasted bun
where's the burger
ah there she is
there's the book
you probably won't like that either
how is everything bad does anyone see
some food in there season it yeah salt
pepper uh we don't add anything to it
when wow the meat's really chewy
as chewy as hell we asked the chef to
taste that okay
damn
thank you welcome
um he said the burger is really chewy he
said try it
it's great
it's chewy uh-huh that's weird
it says on the menu the way mum used to
make that has to be the biggest insult
to every mother
in america
it's embarrassing because those are our
most popular dishes i was really shy
this is kitchen here right can i meet
the chefs introduced me to the uh team
this is kevin my son how are you doing
how are you doing likewise so you're the
head chef yes
and this is your
son right
on a scale of one to ten rate the food
in the restaurant
between six and seven six and seven i
would have said six
half it and take two away and you you're
on my mark
personally i like the food but what the
do i know i was a bricklayer you know
what i'm saying
let me tell you straight and honest okay
the menu is hideous in a dining room
that's miserable the fruit's depressing
and you've got the audacity to call it
classic american you can't even get a
burger right we eat the burgers here
most nights we're proud of that's fruity
seriously yes
yeah
i'm really sorry about your food
i'm a little pissed off right now
i couldn't believe that he sent that
you're a young chef standing by your
mother
totally respect that
but you're pulling it down
and to think that your rating was seven
out of ten
mate you've got issues
and as owners with a huge responsibility
on your shoulders it's like you guys
have disappeared
you're screwed
it's not that i don't try and i have not
given up
i've
tried to do the best it's not that i
don't care and it's not that we're
trying to take stroke cuts
but we've cut back on the payroll and
she's got a baby and she can't be here
he's got a baby and i can't afford to
pay him and i need to pay my people
it's not a comfortable position to be in
i can see that president stop me from
trying
so who's on the payroll here we don't
we're not on payroll so not even the
owners are getting paid we haven't
gotten paid in over a year
i moved back home fill up with my
parents
i knew you had your problems but i
didn't think it was gonna be that bad
the situation's actually worse than i
thought it would be
i'm gonna go for a walk i'm gonna do
some thinking and um
i'll see you
tonight god is depressing
his first impression was that we didn't
care it made me realize we lost our way
come on come here come here come on come
on
he's right you know we lost the heart i
feel so bad i feel bad
it's gotten to the point where this
ain't no joke there's a lot at stake
you need a fresh set of eyes that's what
you need
i'm scared don't worry about it it'll be
all right maybe um we were low scores
[Music]
[Music]
after a lunch in which classic american
dishes were more disgusting than classic
chef ramsay looks to observe how the
restaurant functions in a dinner service
i'll have the ultimate combo uh soup
with the biscuit can i do a sweet potato
five sure that would be great thank you
what's your strength
i'm not really sure you're not really
sure i i'm good with the customers right
and yet you work behind the scenes you
don't from the customers
wow
and what are you doing are you running
around oh i'm the boss boy you're the
best point i do whatever they told me
chef ramsey said hi to me i just looked
up at him because i was scared his hair
is a little crazy even though it looks
soft it's like
[Music]
so when the tickets come on where'd your
tub go they were originally coming out
here this broke so now they hand written
tickets
we used to have a computer but um
somebody spilled coffee all over the
register
and burnt it out we can't afford i need
to fix it ashley what does this say
reuben cut me two focaccias ashley write
the tickets better
so do the tickets take a lot longer to
hand right or well if the writing is
sloppy it tends to get a little
confusing how long has it been to be
down six months maybe
order up even with handwritten tickets
order up order off order up naomi and
kevin managed to push out the food at a
rapid pace thank you you're welcome
the fruit goes out fast isn't it pretty
fast
[Music]
unfortunately the fast food is not
exactly pleasing to many of the
customers just kind of soggy
what's wrong with that they said the
shrimp is no good
what is that
white wine wow so good
the food coming back used to upset me
more but it's happened so often that i
just become numb to it
does anyone ever get bothered about all
the food coming back
yes huh yeah nobody thinks everyone's
taking it
words
i don't know what to do you're right i'm
taking it all in
lightweight i know the feeling
colleen hey listen i know you're
stressed and you got a lot on your mind
but take the reins and run your
restaurant
what can i get for you
can i have spicy tender appetizer and
burger there is no more teresa no
burgers we're out yeah you're gonna have
to 86. how can we 86 a burger sorry with
owner colleen completely shutting down i
really need that chicken for table ten
you're gonna have to wait
a leaderless classic american runs into
problem table three wants meatloaf we
don't have meatloaf after problem we
have no copper i need these cleaned
immediately after problem
[Music]
leaving the customers unhappy
it just doesn't make any sense to me and
the staff frustrated
cable 56 has been waiting 18 minutes for
something to drink because i have no
coke
i know colleen's really stressed out how
could you run a business when you don't
have enough silver you don't have enough
coffee can i have a cup
uh there are there girl in there there's
none in there you know who would want to
come to the restaurant like that that's
so unorganized i wouldn't dress i need
soup cups can you please wash them out
there's nothing there there's two in
there right now oh my god nope soup cops
like how did they accept me to serve
yeah okay
gosh god
wash dishes wash dishes i can't i gotta
i can't do this tonight i really can't i
can't you gotta go work the line because
i'm losing my mind
it's two hours into dinner service the
kitchen has run out of everything from
burgers teresa no burgers we're out yeah
it's a coffee what's even good no don't
say that and owner colleen has just run
out of patience
i can't i gotta i can't do this tonight
i really can't
what's the matter
i've been fighting a losing battle every
day you're standing there and you're not
getting anywhere and i just keep going
and going and going you understand
i do understand and i can see how
painful it is i feel disappointed in
myself
i feel like i've failed
and i've tried hard you know
[Music]
at the end of the day
it's your family and it's your friends
and it's not malicious and nobody's out
to hurt
but i'm frustrated and i'm angry and i'm
scared i'm really really scared i feel i
had more lose than anybody else in this
place
excuse me here's the the honest truth
the
the standards have been accepted too low
and in amongst those standards there's a
big friendship
friendship's got more to do with it
because there's no friends when that
place is closed they get their next job
six months three months two weeks they
move on
and you're spending the rest your life
reducing that debt
you're right you're absolutely right
i need this to stay no but it's not
gonna get better if you keep on doing
the same thing right and i know that
i cannot give up
okay
no
let's go finish the service
yeah
i've never met a woman with as much on
their shoulders as colleen
and today's been a bad day but tomorrow
i'll have to pick her up and get those
standards up there
and she's got a set an example
in his first 24 hours chef ramsay
realized that there are many problems at
classic american and high on his
priority list is fixing the lack of
communication
here's an exercise this morning that i
need
everybody to be open to
i want to find out the problems you have
with each other
i want each of you to
write down
to questions to issues
ask anything you want open house
this is not gonna go well people don't
like to be confronted here
thank you
okay so on the questions
colleen why'd you always seem frustrated
at the waitresses
here we go
because
when these customers walk through that
door you're the first person that they
see then
they're not getting the service if
they're sitting there and you're texting
on your phone they're paying customers
they deserve your attention not the
person on the phone
ashley teres you don't text in the
middle of service when customers are
waiting for stuff to do
you text when customers are
wow
naomi why are you such a pushover
because they're my family
they're not though
your family's at home and this is your
business
and the difference is night and day you
have to change
i have to work on that okay um dom
why we're always running out of product
i don't close every night at the end of
the day everything's got to be stocked
and written down what we need but
i'm right you're not right before you
make an order
okay
you need to go through everything who's
not feeding you the right information he
doesn't wait for information he just
goes i just got true telling you i don't
close every
night
you're always so defensive i'm not we're
not picking on you you always got an
answer you always gotta come back that's
right i gotta comment about everything
because when i open my mouth everybody
shrugs their shoulders and gets up at it
because you do it that's fine that's why
that's right because i see something
because i see something wrong and i say
something and she don't want to be
bothered she spent and you rather walk
around
this is the problem is it you is it him
is it me is it her who who
it's everybody no yeah it is everybody
it don't take one person to run a
business you need a team you need a team
but you need a chief exactly and ain't
no chief here
who signs the checks you or us okay
you're right
i was ready to kill somebody
you don't disrespect me like that
they gotta fight the way to piss me off
this ain't no joke these girls are in
debt obtain their heads
they got to get it we got to stay in
business
colleen
you and naomi
you need to
lead this business i need you to be
tough naomi
because if you're not everybody just
does as they please text serve
home
and if you cannot lead
you shouldn't have bought this place
you shouldn't have done it
[Music]
after an explosive it's everybody no
yeah it is everybody yet revealing you
need to
lead this business staff meeting no me
okay only two seconds chef ramsay knows
he needs to help colleen and naomi take
charge of the restaurant i need to make
sure this service starts to go the way
we want it and he begins by assigning
the owner's new rules for tonight's
dinner service i want you expediting and
i want you working with these two
boss in the kitchen and boss in the
front of the house
i'm very anxious right now it was a long
time ago since i spent a night in the
dining room you've got to show me
quickly why you own this place and what
it means to you we're opening half an
hour yeah okay let's go
[Music]
time for some changes yes
chef ramsay has also added a special to
tonight's menu
giving a modern spin to an american
classic
let's start off with some sliders fun
and bite-sized yeah that is a thousand
miles away from the bomb burger yeah
have a taste
[Music]
how's that perfect try and chew it
before you swallow it yes easy
we have a slider special which i think
they're gonna sell out the door it's
starting to feel like this restaurant is
taking a turn for the better
not texting
sorry
no no no no no
no what happened who are you texting
salon hair nails
i got back to text messaging
run your business tonight and let's make
one big step in the right direction
thank you let's go
how are you hi money
you're welcome how are you two sure as
word of chef ramsay's visit spreads you
can have a seat here i'll bring your
menus right over this once quiet
restaurant is even busier than the
previous night your menus will be right
out
i have no more uh
menus i just i really need menus for 15.
you want to take an order on eleven so i
can have those menus you have to wait
for a menu which is crazy why is it so
slow we only have 13 menus we only have
how many 13.
can you have a seat right here your
menus will be right out 50 seats and 13
million trust us to run out on number 13
right i just wanted to hide there was
people standing at the door i was under
so much pressure we didn't have enough
money to print any more money so
we had what we had 13 menus you're
kidding me i told you it was hell here
yeah you're right it's not far from hell
um no me set those customers down
i'd much rather sit down with no menu
i'm standing in the corridor staring at
you as soon as i finish those my knees
pass on the next time
thank you
here you go
after a slow start caused by the menu
shortage you want to just get slider
yeah and then we'll just put that
special triangle the trio has your meal
orders are finally taken i'm gonna need
two more sliders many of which include
chef ramsay sliders
[Music]
which gets the evening off on a positive
note that's good
they said it was excellent i need
sliders mac and cheese and crab cake app
okay uh colleen yes but you open it up
now start getting the team together yeah
i'm trying i'm trying an hour into
dinner service the kitchen led by
colleen and her son kevin are having a
hard time keeping up with the orders
table 8 needs their food they've been
waiting so long he knows everyone's
waiting a long time
and the mood in the dining room is
starting to turn i don't even remember
what i ordered if they don't make it now
they will leave
food will be out shortly everything just
stumbled i was doing the best that i
could do table three has been waiting a
really long time yeah they're not
waiting any longer than these people but
these tables came in at six o'clock back
walk please
i understand
as colleen begins to get a grip of the
kitchen once again that's the table one
food slowly makes its way out to the
dining room
[Music]
but the customers
are far from impressed oh my god how
gross is that just send it back it's
terrible
they didn't like the calamari
excuse me
can i get this one like a little less
awesome really spicy super spicy
it was crazy he would like less sauce
definitely just want to bury your head
in the sand how much sausage you know we
put on that kevin about that much choice
usually take it by that tell me that's
normal yeah it's wrong
[Music]
kevin if that's normal you're abnormal
two season salads going to table 12. the
mother and son team are finally pushing
food out where's that going hold on
but a disturbing dish catches chef
ramsay's watchful eye look at that just
touch it
a plate of vegetables fingers going
right through it this is the sorry steak
that we've got ourselves into if we are
going to continue serving that
close your business
close it stop i wouldn't say that to my
dog tonight's dinner service has been
plagued with
and let me problems send it back it's
terrible they didn't like the column
but this last broccoli dish look at that
was the last straw for chef ramsay if we
are going to continue serving that
close your business
close it
[Music]
all over there for me stop
stop
don't send anything else
close it
[Music]
we're closed
these are closed
can i get away
i'm sorry we're not serving anymore
tonight was terrible tonight was a
nightmare
i didn't want to face chef ramsay i
don't want to face my employees i just
wanted everybody to go away because it
was horrendous
okay
tonight was
ridiculous
instead of making progress
we went backwards more than i ever
thought
was possible
tonight
i realized
there's no way this restaurant can
survive
unless there's a dramatic change
tomorrow from the minute you arrive it's
gonna be change i have to change after
change get ready for that
agreed
yes
good night
we just lost our way i'm hoping chef
ramsay can put us back on track
[Music]
chef ramsay knows that this
dysfunctional restaurant needs a massive
overhaul in order for it to have any
chance of surviving
so he goes to work immediately after the
staff leaves working through the night
to give classic american a dramatic
makeover
[Music]
right good morning good morning ready
see your new restaurant
yes yes okay guys let's go the new
classic america come in
can we come in
beautiful wow
[Laughter]
come in come here colleen come in
gone as the old country style whatever
it was
and welcome to the new classic america
beautiful light vibrant
what do you think colleen
talk to me darling
are you happy
i'm jumping out of my skin
this is more than i could imagine and
it's nice to have tears of happiness
instead of sadness beautiful me what do
you think
looks great we got rid of those
horrendous tablecloths now we've got
some vibe some lightness some excitement
this place is gonna be so busy you won't
have time to start handwriting tickets
you're going to need to work with
something that is from the 21st century
and in here
this is the state of the arts pos system
installed by halo
wow absolutely amazing
stock control
price check done those arguments are out
i'm going for bread i'm going for
potatoes i need chicken eat ground beef
it's all in there
good gordon got us this awesome computer
does everything for white beer
i'm afraid to touch it i'm gonna break
it okay
there's one more thing
i need to come outside
[Music]
here
there we are
look at that beautiful color nice
wow
beautiful what'd you get a sign
well it looks great it stands out it
stands out the first time i drove past
it i couldn't even see the logo
we can see it now now it stands out
what do you think i love this color
i love it
thank you
i haven't felt this good in a long time
this is the fresh start we've been
waiting for there's more good news
we have
a menu
for every freaking table yes
now
gone are the 75 items yeah seriously i
love this menu
it's nice
clear we needed menus really bad
i'm really happy
now let's have a look at the new menu
classic american dishes done brilliantly
well got a wedge salad vibrant
slider trio turkey beef and chicken
delicious yeah yes chef turkey swiss
club wonderful the classic american
burger your burger the bomb
has gone
yeah hallelujah
[Music]
[Laughter]
i swear to god who needs a pig in the
back guard we got dom
big deep breath
dom save some for the staff will you
please yeah uh-huh okay dig in
it's so good
[Music]
because if you can cook all this like
this
we won't have a problem
the menu is cool it's exciting there's a
lot of new stuff they looked awesome and
they tasted even better did you eat this
gotta try the corn dog i love the new
menu it was easy it was fresh it was a
lot of new things
i'm excited
i just bit my tongue oh man
i just want to say something i'm going
to cry but i
can't help
the last couple days have been really
rough
but
we pulled through it
and i know
you have to lead by example
and somewhere along the line we got lost
and i just want to apologize for that
and say you know i've gotten a lot of
clarity over the last couple days
[Music]
and in order for anything to work you
have to have leader and you have to have
a strong leader
because
if if you don't have leadership
you can't function we're family
but
we have a business to run okay
so those two things need to be separated
and we will
i promise you
show you the leadership that you need to
do your job okay
it's the moment i've been waiting for it
that's a new beginning for myself as an
owner of a business
first and foremost i love everybody here
so from this point on
we're good
okay
i never saw colleen with that kind of
energy that was a shock and it's a good
feeling i think i'm done yelling at
people
it's time for me to change too
chef ramsay handed this to us
and it's on our shoulders to make this
work we're both going to take the reins
and we're going to be in control of this
place again
[Music]
inspired by the new decor and the
upgraded menu the staff is eager to get
ready for the grand reopening let's have
some fun tonight guys you know it
the owners have decided to split
responsibilities with naomi taking
control of the kitchen you want to cut
your rolls i guess i could cut some
right yeah and colleen leading the staff
in the dining room you need something
take a deep breath ask for help okay
everybody good
all right let's go
[Music]
opening five minutes guys yes coming
ready ready good man
i cannot wait for that first order to
come through on that machine
i need to smell before we do that yeah
tonight is a very big night i feel and
um i'm a little nervous did you get a
lighter yeah
hey guys there's people at the front
door there's nobody here to greet them
where are the girls
not now
ladies
where's
where's ashley
get out here no yes
are you smoking cigarettes out there
yeah look at me no stop are you smoking
cigarettes we were we didn't okay well
let me tell you something let me tell
you something really important
diners are standing in the dining room
waiting to be sat down
i love the time we opened up five
minutes to go come on guys they didn't
ask anybody if they could take a smoke
break they know that service is about to
begin they should have been ready with
the restaurant quickly filling up
several fields shortly the waitresses
rush to redeem themselves did we see any
delicious applications we want we're
gonna get you something to drink to
start and chef ramsay looks to the
owners to finally provide the much
needed leadership at classic american
know me yeah i need a leader cooking to
talk at the same time the hardest thing
in the world to do when you get it right
it's harmony yeah i want to hear it
tonight okay
colleen and i had always just blended in
but it's time to stand out now and it's
on our shoulders to make this work ruby
you're up i need a mac and cheese bite
and a corn dog kevin you got a classic
burger okay two orders of wings all day
got the wings yeah excellent nice keep
it going guys yes yeah yes naomi's
newfound confidence has the kitchen
humming get it going order up ashley
table eight yeah thank you and orders
are flying out of the kitchen enjoy
meanwhile welcome my name is colleen i'm
one of the owners colleen has stepped up
in her role as floor manager table six
is adding a shrimp appetizer oh the
ladies my table yeah but their food is
already in so you have to let the
kitchen know that okay it was really
good to see colleen's actually step up
and tell us what to do and be the leader
take the meatloaf out pull pork right
away let's go
[Music]
surprisingly we get off a good start i'm
a really good start but based on the
performance of this kitchen of the last
10 years i'm not holding out
not yet
all right kevin turkey burger with onion
rings just put it up
[Music]
guys
guys look
i'm not gonna say that underneath there
you bust your ass like that to create
fantastic food you've got to serve it on
place your crap underneath
look all over the place come on i cannot
afford for you to take your eye off the
ball now please yeah see that i was
nervous and i was trying to get in the
zone that's when all the mistakes start
to happen you've got to keep on driving
yeah come on keep it going but we'll
pull together and we'll step up and
we'll get past it just watch the bottom
of the plate to me there's nowhere else
to move before
there you go excellent table line
after looking after a small hiccup this
kitchen led by naomi is back in its
groove
how is everything
good you like it good choice and
delivering high quality dishes that are
striking a cord with customers how do we
like everything absolutely delicious
we'll come back for more all right trust
me okay
as dinner winds down and happy customers
leave the restaurant thank you
bye
it is clear that these two owners under
the guidance of chef ramsay stay
together guys stay together have just
made the greatest comeback
in kitchen nightmare's history how are
we doing guys doing good filming
tickets yeah we're cleared the board
kelly place is full the ball is clear
the customers are happy yeah come on
keep it going yeah behind everybody all
the way watching the customers
enjoying what they were eating that's
what you're here for that's why you bust
your ass you know from this point on
it's a new beginning good night thank
you very much
[Music]
okay
let's be honest this has been a very
difficult turnaround yeah
but you all pulled off a fantastic
service congratulations
amazing
colleen how's it feel i felt great i'm
proud of each and every one of them
everybody worked hard yes and
nami hearing your voice calling
commanding assertive is really important
because it just puts that discipline
across the line and more importantly
you're good at it
colleen know me this restaurant has
every potential
to really seriously become a huge
success
do not
start dropping in standard it means too
much
yes
well done
well done well done
well done
come here
well done
well done
i want to thank chef ramsay for giving
us this opportunity to start all over
again it's a dream come true you're on
your way good night
there's only one word to describe what
happened here tonight that's a miracle i
only hope that these two former
waitresses can finally achieve their
classic american dream
jeez 50 seats 13 menus
wait
after chef ramsay left colleen and naomi
continued to run classic american like a
well-oiled machine kevin you need two
chickens on um maybe you should jump on
dishes for a little bit all right
the owners also implemented a loyalty
system to reward repeat customers these
are punch cards okay at the end you get
your meal free that's a great idea
since then the staff is happy i love
this computer i love it business is
booming we will be back i guarantee that
and classic american looks poised to
become a classic success
i feel alive and feels good to finally
be able to smile again that's a new
beginning
[Music]
you